[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام عام على الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه فماذا بعد لا حل سياسي
يلوح في الافق ولا حسم عسكري على الارض في
ظل تحشيد غربي لدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
وسياسيا مقابل اصرار روسي على المضي قدما
على جبهات عده داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
عشرات الجلسات لمجلس الامن ومثلها عقوبات
غربيه بالجمله على موسكو لم تكفي لنزع
فتيل الحرب والجلوس على طاوله الحوار فيما
حرب التصريحات بين موسكو وكياف لم تهدا
ولو ليوم واحد من 300 وخمسه وستين يوما
مضت التغطيه من العربيه مستمره فاهلا بكم
مجددا
[موسيقى]
الممثل الكوميدي حافظ على دور البطوله لكن
مسرحه اليوم بمساحه تفوق 600 الف كيلو متر
حيث يستحوذ دور البطوله في اوكرانيا كلها
ساحه قتال مستعره منذ عام على الارض
يقابلها مواجهه بين
الخلفيه الفنيه
احد اكثر رجالات العالم حنكه بالسياسه
والحروب
[موسيقى]
اعلن الرئيس البولندي اندريه دوده انه
ناقش مع نظيره الامريكي جو بايدن امكانيه
انتاج مشترك للذخائر لصالح اوكرانيا وقال
دودار ان هذه المحادثات ستستمر كان مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعلن ان الدول الاعضاء ستعتمد على
مخزوناتها لتسريع توريد الاسلحه والذخيره
الى اوكرانيا لكن المخزونات الغربيه
تتناقص وبالتالي فمن الضروري تجديدها
[موسيقى]
هذا وقال البيت الابيض في تصريح للعربيه
ان اي اتفاق سلام يجب ان ياخذ بعين
الاعتبار سياده اوكرانيا وان المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه لا تشير الى ان الصين بصدد
تقديم دعم عسكري لروسيا اما بشان الدوري
الايراني فصرح المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان ايران ارسلت لروسيا
قطع دبابات ومدفعيه لاستخدامها في معاركها
باوكرانيا وان واشنطن تعتقد بان روسيا قد
تزود ايران بطائرات مقاتله واضاف كذلك بان
ايران تحاول الحصول على مليارات الدولارات
من روسيا مقابل اعتاد عسكري كما اشار الى
ان مجموعه السبع ركزت على تكثيف الدعم
لاوكرانيا كي تنتصر
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان دول العالم ستواصل دعمها
لاوكرانيا مضيفا في كلمه له في مجلس الامن
الدولي ان هذا الدعم سيمنع فردا نظام
عالمي يسيطر فيه القوي على الضعيف ويسمح
بمحو حدود دول والاستيلاء على دول اخرى
بحسب وصفه
جميع الدول حول العالم تدعم اوكرانيا
لاننا نقر جميعا باننا لو تخلينا عن
اوكرانيا فنحن بذلك نتخلى عن ميثاق الامم
المتحده بحد ذاته وعن القواعد التي تضمن
امننا جميعا وسلامتنا ان الاستيلاء على
الاراضي بالقوه ومحو حدود دوله اخرى
واستهداف مدنيين في الحروب امور غير مقبول
بها وان لم ننتصر لمبادئنا فهذا سيجعلنا
امام عالم يسيطر فيه القوي على الضعيف وهو
العالم الذي انشئت من اجله هذه المنظمه
بوضع حد لها
ينضم الينا من مسك من منسك مراسل العربيه
عبد الجواد الرشد من واشنطن ناديه
البلبيسي ومن حذيفه عادل على امل ان يلتحق
بنا مراسل العربيه رائد الاخضر من شمال
بعد قليل اهلا بكم جميعا وابدا يعني معك
حذيفه عادل من كياف ارض المعركه الاساسيه
ولو ليس كعاصمه بشكل دائم او كمكان جغرافي
ولكن كعاصمه لاوكرانيا اقصد هل اتضح اكثر
الموقف الاوكراني على لسان زيلنسكي وقد
تحدث الليله كثيرا عن
ما بات يعرف بالخطه الصينيه للحل
تحياتي طاهر لك ولي الزملاء في الحقيقه
نعم يعني تحدث زيلينسكي لما يزيد عن
الساعتين او قرابه الثلاث ساعات الى
الصحفيين في مؤتمر صحفي اجابه على عدد
كبير من الاسئله بخصوص الصين طبعا عبر
بشكل واضح عن رغبته في مقابله او لقاء
الرئيس الصيني وايضا اجرام وبحثات معه
وقال ان العلاقه لا تتوقف عند الحرب وراي
الصين في الحرب وانما لدينا علاقات
اقتصاديه كبيره جدا وتبادل تجاري كبير جدا
ولذلك ارغب في مقابلته وفي اجرام وحثات
معه كذلك طبعا تحدث الى الصيغه الصينيه
وقال انها ليست صيغه سلام حتى الان وليست
حتى مبادره وانما هي اراء الصين وقال
يمكننا النظر في اراء الصين حول هذا الامر
وقال طالما الصين يعني تعترف وتقر بوحده
وسلامه اراضينا فهذا يجعله يجعل من الممكن
ان هنالك حوار ونقاش حول هذا الامر ولكن
حتى الان قال ان هذا مجرد حديث ماذا بعد
الحديث يجب على الصين ان تقوم بخطوات
واضحه في انهاء الاحتلال الروسي للاراضي
الاوكرانيه باسرع ما يمكن ويجب ان تدعم
هذا الموقف وقال ايضا ان صيغه السلامه
الاوكرانيه تناولت جميع الجوانب لذلك هو
يرغب طبعا في ان تدعم الصين صيغه السلام
الاوكرانيه والتي تعتمد على ان يكون هنالك
ضمانات امنيه وتعلم ان صيغه السلام
الاوكرانيه نفسها وضعت الصين واحده من
الدول الضامنه لصيغه السلام الاوكرانيه في
بنود كثيره من ضمنها ان تضمن ان لا يكون
هنالك اعتداء واذا حدث اعتداء ان تزود كيف
بالاسلحه وان تشارك في جميع العقوبات التي
ستعرض على الدوله المعتديه في حال حدوث
ذلك روسيا طبعا ثملت المبادره ولكن قد
يكون هناك ملاحظات نتعرف من عبد الجواد
الرشد وانت معنا من منسك اذا ما كان ذلك
بات واضحا ومعروفا بتفاصيله الان
ردود الخارجيه الروسيه ومختلف المؤسسات
الروسيه على ما بدر من الخطه الصينيه حتى
الان
مساء الخير طاهر لك ولزملاء مجددا نعم
يعني منذ نحو ساعتين كنا نتحدث واياك حول
ان موسكو تقوم الان بدراسه الطرح الصيني
بما يخص يعني اعاده وحل الازمه الاوكرانيه
بطرق السلميه طبعا موسكو وتحدثت بعد ذلك
على لسانه الخارجيه بانها منفتحه بشكل
مباشر حول تحصيل اهداف العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالطرق
السلميه والدبلوماسيه هي رساله طبعا
وجهتها موسكو رساله مبطنه الى الغرب بان
موسكو جاهزه اليوم من جديد للجلوس لطاوله
المفاوضات هو بصيص امل ظهر لدى الدائره
السياسيه في البلاد طاهر والقراءه
السياسيه للمحللين الذين بداوا يتحدثون عن
ضروره العوده لطاوله المفاوضات بالرغم من
انقطاع واختفاء الثقه بين موسكو والغرب
طبعا الطرح الصيني تبعه اتصال بين الرئيس
التركي والرئيس الروسي تحدث فيه الجانبان
عن امور عند ابرزها هو طرح تركيا بانها
جاهزه للعوده مباشره ولعب دور في الوساطه
بين الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني والروسي
والغرب طبعا لذلك الامور يعني على ما يبدو
انها تتجه نوعا ما بارسال رسائل من قبل
موسكو بان جاهزه للجلوس طاوله المفاوضات
خاصه بعد خروج تقارير غربيه تتحدث عن ان
باريس وبرلين يعني تحدثتاه مع الرئيس
ايزيلنسكي وطلبه منه يعني بدا عمليه
الحوار صحيح وهنا ياتي اهميه الدور
الامريكي في كل ذلك بين المواقف الشرقيه
الروسيه والصينيه ومواقف الاتحاد الاوروبي
ويعني على راس ذلك ياتي الموقف الامريكي
لنعرف اين تتجه الامور وهنا اتحول الى
ناديه البلبيسي من واشنطن لعلها
ناديه ابرز هذه المواقف هل يمكن ان نقول
بوضوحها تماما فيما يتعلق بالرفض او
بالوسطيه او بقبول بعض البنود على الاقل
مما طرح وعرف من هذه المبادره الصينيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك طاهر واهلا بالزملاء طبعا يعطيهم
الف عافيه على العمل الميداني على الارض
قبل قليل انا سالت في الواقع جونكر بهذا
السؤال بالنسبه للطرح الروسي عفوا الصيني
او ما يسمى بالمبادره الصينيه جونكر بي
قال لنا بانه لو وقفت الصين فقط على البند
الاول والثاني ربما كان مقبولا بين قوسين
باي معنى بمعنى بانه تتحدث الصين اولا على
سياده الدول وبالتالي تتحدث عن سياده
اوكرانيا هذا ما يهم الولايات المتحده
طبعا حاولت ان اقول له هل ترى بان هذه
المبادره هي جديه هل ممكن الولايات
المتحده ان تاخذها على محمل الجد اذا قرات
ما بين السطور استطيع ان اقول بان واشنطن
بالفعل لا تعتبرها مبادره جديه هناك من
يروج بانها مبادره تحظى باهتمام روسيا فقط
وبالتالي هناك ايضا حديث على ان الاداره
تريد ان ربما تنشر معلومات استخباريه تثبت
بان الصين تفكر جدي في تصليح روسيا ومن
هنا تاتي هذه ربما المفارقه بالنسبه
للمواقف الامريكيه لكن بشكل عام الولايات
المتحده الموقف واضح بالنسبه لها عندما
ياتي الموضوع بالنسبه لوحده اراضي وسياده
اوكرانيا هذا موضوع خط احمر بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده رغم انها دوما تقول طبعا
الامر يعود الى اوكرانيا وانها لن تخطو
باي خطوه سواء كانت بالسلام او بموضوع اخر
الا بموافقه من الحكومه في كيف موقف
واشنطن واضح جدا ملتزم جدا بدعم اوكرانيا
من كل النواحي دبلوماسيا وعسكريا وتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه والاقتصاديه ايضا
وكما ذكرت ربما اهم ما جرى اليوم هو لقاء
الرئيس بايدن مع مجموعه دول السبع وكان
فيها وقال فيها بايدن بالتحديد بانه روسيا
بامكانها هي التي بدات هذه الحرب وهي التي
بامكانه ان تنهي هذه الحاله اليوم حافل
بدون شك على مستوى العالم في متابعه
الذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
ودنيتك بيكون بدون شك مشتعله ميدانيا
دائما وايضا مشتعله اثناء الحديث السياسي
اذا ما كانت تشملها السياده الاوكرانيه ام
لا وفق ما سيتبلغ
اهلا بكم من جديد بين التكتيك
والاستراتيجيه كثيره كانت التحركات
العسكريه على الجبهات الاوكرانيه بدا
الروس حربهم ب 190 الف جندي كانوا وقود
المعارك المشتعله قبل الاضطرار لاعاده
التعبئه الجزئيه في اكتوبر الماضي ليصل
عددهم الى 220 الفا واليوم تشير التقديرات
الى 330 الف عنصر بين جنود وقوه انفصاليه
ومتطوعين وطبعا مرتزقه كيف كانت التحركات
طوال السنه الاولى من الحرب الاجابه مع
الزميله حني نشولي
عملنا طويل لدى بوتين واطول منه لدى
الاوكرانيين وبنهايته ابتعدت جدا احلام
العوده الى الشهر الاول من الحرب
الاوكرانيه الرابعه عشر من مارس روسيا
تستولي على سبعه وعشرين في المئه من
اوكرانيا اكثر من ربع بلاد من الجنوب
بمساحته الزراعيه الشاسعه وتحديدا في
خرسون الى الشمال محطه شرنوبل وممر بري
يصل الى حافتكييف كانت هذه ذروه النجاح
الروسي ومن قمته جاء السقوط الحر في ابريل
الى قاع الفشل على ابواب العاصمه
الاوكرانيه انسحب الروس من شمال وشمال شرق
اوكرانيا في الثامن من ابريل لتبدا
المرحله الثانيه كما اسمها بوتين بخساره
40% من مكاسب الميدان من مايو وحتى نهايه
اغسطس خطوات بطيئه في الشرق حققت مكسبين
ماريوبول نهايه مايو ولوجانسك
لم يستشعر بوتين في غمار محاوله جيشه
السيطره على دنيتك العاصفه القادمه من
خركيب العاشر من سبتمبر اكبر تقدم للجيش
الاوكراني في يوم واحد على حساب انسحاب
الروس في الشمال الشرقي باكثر من 50
كيلومترا والمساحه تحمل اهميتها انسحب
الجيش الروسي من مدينتيوم وكوبيانس
المركزين اللوجستيين لدومباس في اسبوع
واحد فقط من الهجوم المضاد كانت المكاسب
الاوكرانيه من الاراضي اكبر مما استولت
عليه القوات الروسيه في الاشهر الخمسه
الماضيه هل يعني ذلك ان روسيا تخسر الحرب
لا الضمه لاربع مقاطعات انقذها واكسبها
وسته عشر الف كيلو مترا مربع طبعا مع
القرم ونتحدث هنا عن مساحه دوله بحجم
بلغاريا غير ان المكسب او ربعه لم يدم
طويلا في العاشر من نوفمبر تنسحب القوات
الروسيه من خرسون وهي اول مقاطعه سقطت تحت
السيطره الروس تخليها مع محيطها على طول
الضفه الغربيه لنهر دينيبرو موسكو سحبت
اربعين الف جنديا من المنطقه
باستعادتي خرسون توجت اوكرانيا مكاسبها من
هجومها المضاد مسترجعه وخمسين في المئه من
اراضيها لكن الحرب رمال متحركه في الخامس
والعشرين من يناير الماضي القوات
الاوكرانيه تنسحب من صوليدار شرقا بعد
اقتحام قوه المعادله العسكريه الروسيه
بقوه وتصدرها مشهد الحرب في اعقاب التباطؤ
الشتوي المكسب مهم سوليدار بدرجه اقل
المكسب الحقيقي على بعد عشره كيلو مترات
ولاجله سجلت اكثر المعارك دمويه في الحرب
محمود في دنيا هي الحصن على حد وصف الرئيس
الاوكراني
والبوابه الوحيده للروس في تقدم سيطرتهم
على المقاطعه الانفصاليه مخموت تفتح
الطريق نحو مدينتي كراماتورس
الرئيسيتين تشكلان مع مقاطعتي
الحوض الصناعيه الكبير في اوكرانيا
ارسلت بولندا اليوم الدفعه الاولى من
دبابات ليوبار 2 من اصل اربعه عشره دبابه
كانت قد وعدت بها اوكرانيا واعلن رئيس
الوزراء البولندي
ماتيوسكي عن ارسال الشحنه الاولى خلال
زيارته الى كياف تزامنا مع ذكرى بدء
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وكانت بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده وفرنسا اعلنت تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات في حربها
في المقابل اعلن وزير الدفاع البريطانيه
بان والاس ان بلاده لن تقوم بتزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات تايفون في المستقبل
القريب واضاف واليس ان امدادات طائرات
المقاتله سيتطلب ارسال مئات الاشخاص بينهم
مهندسون وطيارون مشيرا الى ان الغرب لن
يرسل قوات الى اوكرانيا بهذا الحجم لكن
يمكن ان ترسل بريطانيا 200 شخص من سلاح
الجو الملكي في وقت اخر ولكن ليس في هذه
المرحله
اطراف حرب اوكرانيا تعد عدتها لخوض حرب
الدبابات الثقيله في الربيع والصيف
المقبلين وكلاه يتحدث عن حرب طويله في
غضون العام الاول من هذه الحرب يعتقد حلف
الناتو ان روسيا قد فشلت في تحقيق اهدافها
في نهايه عامها الاول تدخل حرب اوكرانيا
منعطفه معركه الدبابات الثقيله التي تدفع
بها الدول الغربيه الى سهول اوكرانيا بعد
تزويدها بمختلف المضادات وانظمه الدفاع
الجوي اليات غربيه تبدو في عين موسكو
مقدمه لاعاده معركه قبل 80 عاما
قبل ما يناهز العام اطلقت روسيا حمله غزو
شامله ضد اوكرانيا حيث فجرت اكبر نزاع في
اوروبا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه ولا
نرى اي مؤشر على استعداد روسيا للسلام
اقتحام القوات الروسيه ترابا اوكرانيا في
شهر فبراير العام الماضي دفع حلف شمال
الاطلسي الى مضاعفه قدراته العسكريه في
دول السفع الشرقي وفق مقرراته قمه النيتو
الاستثنائيه
حلف الناتو
مثل ما هو الحال عليه اليوم بوتين يواجه
بالضبط عكس ما يتوقعه جراء ما فعله في
اوكرانيا
حلف الناتو نشر اربعه كتائب قتاليه في كل
من المجر والسوفاكيا ورومانيا وبلغاريا
تضاف لاربع كتائب منتشره منذ خمس سنوات في
بولندا ودول البلطيق الثلاث دول الحلف
وضعت اربعين الفا من القوات الخاصه تحت
امره النيتو واستنفرت 130 طائره ومئه
واربعين سفينه حربيه من مياه الشمال
البارده الى المتوسط الدافئ مرورا بمياه
البحر الاسود الولايات المتحده من ناحيتها
نشرت مئه الف جندي في اوروبا
قبل نحو عام توقع بوتين ان تكون اوكرانيا
هدفا سهلا بوتين توقع سقوطك بسرعه وتوقع
ايضا ان العالم سيقف غير مبالغ الكرملين
اخطا حساباته كافه
حرب اوكرانيا تدخل عامها الثانيه وسط سباق
حربي محموم بين روسيا واوكرانيا مدعومه من
دول الناتو بين دوله قد تستخدم السلاح
النووي اذا تعرضت للهجومي ودول بعضها
نوويه تمتلك احدث الاسلحه
حان الوقت للعوده الى الوراء والتعامل مع
الوضع بواقعيه وبالنسبه للقول اننا سننتصر
في هذه الحرب لا احد سينتصر الوحيد الذي
ينتصر في هذه الحرب هو الذي يتمكن من
وقفها ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنها
دول ناشئه عده قادره على الاطلاع بدور
الوساطه لانهاء حرب مدمره اذا قبلت اطراف
النزاع وتنازلت عن شيء من كبريائها رودين
الفريد العربي بروكسل
ينضم الى ان ملكيه
الاوكرانيه السابق اهلا بك معنا في هذه
التغطيه المستمره من العربيه ما حقيقه
الموقف الاوكراني نحاول ان نفهم من ضيوفنا
حقيقه الموقف الاوكراني الان بعد ما ذكره
الرئيس الينسكي من المبادره الصينيه تحدث
عن قبول بعض الافكار ولكن نتحدث عن انسحاب
هل موضوع السياده الذي ذكرته الصين اذا لا
تعتبره كييف بندا واضحا الانسحاب القوات
الروسيه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
صحيه طيبه تحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا بصراحه
بالنسبه لنا غريبه بان لم تكون اي مفاوضات
قبل مع اوكرانيا من طرف الصيني اتمنى كل
هذه اقتراحات بصفه عامه اقتراحات الصينيه
غير مقبوله لاوكرانيا بصراحه يبدو لي بان
هذه خطه هذه خطه المحاوله ساذجه
لانقاذ روسيا من هزيمه في هذه الحرب
بصراحه لنكون صريحين يعني بان روسيا
تدريجيا هي لا تفاشلها الحرب وهي فاشله
هذا حرب استراتيجيا ان هدف عند روسيا كانت
تتغير نظام في اوكرانيا وعدم خروج
اوكرانيا من منطقه النفوس روسيه انا لن
اعلاميه الاوكرانيه والغربيه تقول دائما
بخساره روسيا رغم ضمها العدد الاكبر من
المناطق الاستراتيجيه التي خسرتها كييف
وتريدها
ايما اراده موسكو بشكل اساسي وهذا ما
تقوله دائما هي لا تريد كيف تريد تلك
المناطق الغنيه بكل شيء وخسرتموها
بصراحه هذا
ليست منطقه
تقلل اهدافها الان بسبب الاخفاقات كمان
نحن نشاهد عند رؤوسنا الرغبه تجميد هذه
حرب هذا الصراع وانا عليقين سوف تستخدم
هذه مهله لتعزيز قواتها باقي روسيا صوت
تهاجمه على اوكرانيا مره تانيه مره
بمناسبه بهذا السابق نحن نقول بان الصيغه
الذهبيه لاوكرانيا
وانضمام الى الناتو لان الناتو هو الضمان
تهاجم على اوكرانيا في مستقبل ولكن الان
بصراحه الصينيه تقول بوقف تمدد نحو
التكتلات العسكريه الكبرى المقصود انضمام
اوكرانيا الى حلف الناتو ولك بغض النظر عن
المبادره الصينيه انتم بحاجه الى ان
تعرفوا الى اي مدى يمكن للغرب ان يقف معكم
ان يصمد معكم المعلومات اليوم تقول بان
برلين وباريس طلبت من الرئيس ذا لانسكي ان
ينفتح على المبادره الصينيه
انه ولكن كمان لينا كنا صراحين بان من
بدايته خربطه غرب وكمان فرنسا والمانيا
تنازلات
لروسيا ولكن على كل حال الان نحن نشاهد
بان غرب تقدم لاوكرانيا وعادات عسكريه
ومنها دبابات
ومدراعته كما نحن نرى بان موجود الضوء حيث
غرب حول تقديم لاوكرانيا الاسلحه مختلفه
اسلحه هجوم ولكن هناك يعني واحد موجود
الضوء
هذا توقيت مات اوكرانيا سوف تحصل على كل
هذه المعادلات عسكريه مطلوبه بالمناسبه
اوكرانيا طلبت من غرب تقديم المدرعات
وكمان دبابات من بدايه الحرب صحيح ولكن لا
تنسى انه اكثر من نصف المساعدات لم تصل
حتى الان رغم كل الوعود اليوميه لا تنسى
ليوبارد كم اخذت من نقاشات ومن مخاوف
وهواجس عند حلفائكم الذين يدعمون بقوه
لانهم لا يريدون ان يحرقوا كل الجسور مع
موسكو يعني افلا تنظر كياف الى مثل هذه
المعطيات ايضا لكي تحاول ان تسهم في ايجاد
حل
انا
ادرك هذا
اكيد عن غرب لا يرغب يحرق كل جسور روسيا
انما زال غرب وخاصه الاتحاد
روسيا ولكن هذا كل حال ينبغي ادراك بان
اوكرانيا معزت اسلحه نوويه من اجل السلام
في علمنا معاصره اوكرانيا اسلحه
استراتيجيه مختلفه ومنها صواريخ باليستيه
وطائرات استراتيجيه ودعمت روسيا ودام
ومنها بريطانيا امريكا
ضمانات لاوكرانيا يعني ضمنه حمايه حدود
اوكرانيه واستقلال اوكرانيا وبهذا السبب
اوكرانيا عنده اوكرانيا حق معنوي بنطلب من
غرب كل اسلحه المطلوبه بالمناسبه لنتذكر
سنه 2014 عندما روسيا
سرقت من اوكرانيا
وهاجمت في منطقه
20% من اراده
غير مترفه بها فلنتذكر بان
غرب اراد استرداد
بوتين باراضي اوكرانيه بتنازلات مثل
منطقه
سنوات
هو هجمه على اوكرانيا بشكل شامل ونحن كما
ندرك اليوم اوكرانيا
في غربهم كمان يدركون هذا وبهذا السابق
موجود مساعده ضخمه لاوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا
لك
حرب موازيه للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
دارت رحاها على مستوى وسائل الاعلام مع
بدايه الحرب كان الاعلام وسيله لبث روايه
كل طرف لتلعب كل من موسكو ودول الغرب على
وتر حظر وسائل الاعلام الاتحاد الاوروبي
منع قناتي روسيا اليوم وسبوتنيك من البث
في دوله
وتوسعت دائره الحظر الى منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه من نشر محتواها
الرد الروسي كان بالمثل
بوتين اصدر قانونا يحكم بالسجن على من
ينشر معلومات كاذبه عن الجيش الروسي
ويليها قرارات وقف مواقع عده منها
وقف رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريشيسوناك
دقيقه صمت في العاصمه البريطانيه لندن
وذلك حدادا على ضحايا الحرب الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
قال مندوب روسيا لدى الامم المتحده في
جلسه خاصه لمجلس الامن حول مرور عام على
الحرب في اوكرانيا قال انه لا يجب اعطاء
امتيازات لاوكرانيا على حساب روسيا
يتم اعطاء بعض الامتيازات لاوكرانيا ويحرم
منها اعضاء اخرون مثلا خلال اجتماع
افريقيا الوسطى في الحادي والعشرين من
فبراير كان وزير الخارجيه حاضرا وتحدث بعد
اعضاء المجلس وذلك ما حدث ايضا خلال
اجتماع حول مالي كذلك الشان حول هايتي
هناك الكثير من الامثله لم تكن هناك حاله
واحده طلبت فيها الوفود الغربيه باعطاء
الكلمه للممثلين من افريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه هو دول اخرى باستثناء اوكرانيا
للتحدث قبل اعضاء المجلس
اضاف خلال الجلسه ذاتها ان مجلس الامن
لديه تناقضات كبيره وانتماءات جيوسياسيه
وانه لا قيمه مضافه لتوسيع عضويه المجلس
ببلدان غربيه
ما نشهده اليوم ما هو الا محاوله جديده
لاعطاء الامتيازات لبعض الدول لانها جزء
من اهتماماتكم الجيوسيه وكان بقيه العالم
لا يعنيكم يؤسفون ان الرئاسه المالطيه تغض
الطرف عن نظام المجلس لا قيمه مضافه
لتوسيع عضويه المجلس ببلدان غربيه لانكم
تحولونه لاداه خاصه بكم
لعبت السعوديه دورا مركزيا في الافراج عن
حوالي عشره اسرع حرب تم اعتقالهم من قبل
قوه الروسيه في اوكرانيا ومنهم الجندي
الامريكي السابق الذي خدم في العراق وفي
افغانستان
العربيه التقت عائله الاسير المحرر في
ولايه البام الجنوبيه ليشارك تفاصيل اسره
واطلاق سراحه بوساطه من ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمى
يختنق صوتها تحاول عبثا ان تمنع دموع ام
ممتنه بعوده ابنها من الاسر
في بيتهم في تسكلوسه في ولايه الاباما
ذهبنا لنسمع من هذه العائله كيف نجحت
الوساطه السعوديه بتعليمات من ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان باطلاق سراح اليكس
دروكي من سجن روسي بعد اعتقاله لمده اربعه
اشهر اليكس تطوع للقتال في صفوف القوات
الاوكرانيه الى ان وقع بالاسر من قبل
الجنود الروس الذين قاموا بتعذيبه وترك
مصيره معلقا بين الحياه والموت
ان اتمكن من تجاوز هذا دون ان ابكي انا
ممتنه جدا لتدخل ولي العهد ومساعدته اعتقد
حقا ان اليكس لن يكون هنا اليوم لو لم يكن
ولي العهد على استعداد تام للمساعده ساكون
مديونه دائما للسعوديه وللشعب ولولي العهد
على وجه الخصوص اليكس الذي يتعافى بعد
الاسر لا يزال يعاني مختلف في الاعصاب
ومتاعب صحيه ويخضع لمراقبه طبيه يحاول ان
ينحت بالخشب ليمرن اصابعه المعطوبه لكنه
يعتبر نفسه محظوظا كونه واحدا من عشر اسرى
حرب تم اطلاق سراحهم بواسطه سعوديه
انتظرنا في المطار ثم اخذونا اخيرا الى
الترام وراينا هناك على المدرسه طائره
سعوديه كبيره وقلنا حسنا هذا ليس حقيقيا
لن يتم وضعنا فيها ثم كنت اتساءل ما هي
تلك الطائره هناك ثم وضعنا فيها وبدا
الموظفون السعوديون في الواقع يتحدثون
الينا ويشرحون ما يجري ويقولون اننا في
امان وانه سوف يطلق صراحنا وانهم سوف
يعتنون بنا لم يكن الامر حقيقيا حتى بطن
في الرياض
سباق مع الزمن من اسره اليكس في محاوله
لاطلاق سراحه ترويها خالته ديانه حيث قامت
بالاتصال مع السينات
ومع وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه لكن الافراج
عنه جاء من جهه لم تتوقعها
لم نكن متاكدين بالضبط من الجهه البسيطه
المساعده ثم عندما علمنا انها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه كان الامر منطقيا بالطبع
لكننا لا زلنا لا نعرف بالضبط كيف حدث ذلك
لا نعرف كيف بدا الامر وكم من الوقت
استغرقت العمليه لاننا كنا نوعا ما في
الظلام اخبرتنا وزاره الخارجيه ان امورا
كانت تحدث لكنهم لم يتمكنوا من اخبارنا
بتفاصيلها
لا شيء يضاهي عوده ابن سالما من حرب بعيده
لكن لدى اسره الدروكي امنيه وحيده وهي شكر
السعوديه على منح ابنها فرصه ثانيه في
الحياه ناديه البلبيسي العربيه تسكلوسا من
ولايه الاباما
برعايه سعوديه عمليه تبادل اسرى بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
العهد السعودي تنجح بالافراج عن عشره
اسرار
الاسرى المحررون من خمس جنسيات المغرب
وامريكا وبريطانيا والسويد وكرواتيا
السعوديه نقلت الاسرى من روسيا الى الرياض
الحادي والعشرون من سبتمبر 2022 وصول
الاسرى العشره الى السعوديه
تاييد دولي واسع لوساطه ولي العهد السعودي
نشكر شركائنا السعوديين على المساعده في
قياده هذه المبادره الانسانيه وتسهيل عوده
عشره رعايه جانب بمن فيهم مواطناني
امريكيان استقبلهما فريق سفاراتنا في
الرياض
كانت مبادره جيده نظرا للعلاقات التي
يمتلكها ولي العهد مع روسيا كانت فرص
النجاح مرتفعه وانا ممتن جدا له على هذه
النتيجه الرائعه
يتابع طبعا الازمه في اوكرانيا وعرض
وساطتها على الطرفان على
روسيا واوكرانيا لايجاد حلها ومنذ ذلك
الحين وهو يتابع التطورات وعند عما علم عن
موضوع هذول الاسرى وصعوبه
خروجهم وتعقيدات لانها كانت عمليه معقده
حقيقه منذ ابريل بدا في الحوار مع الاطراف
وعمل عليها
استمرار خلال الفتره الماضيه الى حين تمت
الصفقه وخرجوا والان في طريقهم الى اهلي
فكان هذا نتيجه حقيقه لاستمرار سموه في
متابعه الامر وحواره المباشر مع جميع
الاطراف
التغطيه من العربيه مستمره ونواصل فيها
بعد هذا الفصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اس 300 منظومه دفاع جوي
روسيه امتلكتها اوكرانيا لتصبح بعد اندلاع
الحرب على راس اولويات موسكو لتدميرها في
المقابل صنعت منظومه صاروخيه الامريكيه
الفارق في هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد نتعرف على
ابرز تفاصيل هاتين المنظومتين في هذا
العرض
سلاح سوفيتي اسر الرئيس الروسي على تدميره
في اوكرانيا منظومه اس 300 سوفيتيه
الشهيره منظومه 300 التي دخلت الخدمه في
عام
1975 تعد من اشهر منظومات الدفاع الجويه
احدى وعشرون دوله حول العالم تمتلك هذه
المنظومه من بينها دولتان عربيه مصر
وسوريا هذا طبعا بالاضافه الى بعض الدول
الاوروبيه مثل اليونان وبلغاريا وايضا
سلوفاكيا في عام
1994 قامت الولايات المتحده بشراء هذه
المنظومه من بيلاروسيا ليس بهدف استخدامها
بكل تاكيد لكن الولايات المتحده كانت تسعى
لكشف نقاط ضعف هذه المنظومه وتدريب
الطيارين الامريكيين على كيفيه تفاديها او
ربما مهاجمتها في بعض الاحيان هذه
المنظومه خضعت لعده عمليات تطوير بهدف
تطويرها الى مستقبل اخر وطراز جديد هذا
الطراز وصل اعتراض الذين نعرفه الان باسم
400 هذه المنظومه التي اثارت ربما ازمات
دبلوماسيه ما بين بعض الدول حاله قيامها
بشرائها من روسيا رغم انتشار هذه المنظومه
فانها لم تحقق النتائج المرجوه منها في
ميادين القتال فشلت مثلا في اسقاط اي
طائرات خلال حرب ناغورنو كاراباخ بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان كما عجزت هذه المنظومه
ايضا عن اسقاط اي طائره اسرائيليه في
سوريا رغم الغارات التي تنفذها اسرائيل
بشكل متكرر في سماء دمشق مع بدايه الحرب
بين روسيا واوكرانيا عمدت روسيا على تدوير
هذه المنظومه التي تمتلكها منذ عهد
الاتحاد السوفيتي لكن بعد فتره اعلنت
سلوفاكيا التبرع بالمنظومه التي تمتلكها
اس 300 منذ عهد الاتحاد السوفيتي الى
اوكرانيا ليس بالمجان بكل تاكيد لكنها
قامت بهذا بعد ان حصلت على وعد امريكي
بتعويضها بمنظومه الشهيره حاله قيامها
بامداد اوكرانيا بهذه المنظومه السوفيتيه
[موسيقى]
دائما ما تكمن قوه اي سلاح في قدرته
التدميريه ومن بين اكثر الاسلحه قدره على
احداث دمار هائل هي قذفات الصواريخ من بين
هذه القذفات والتي اشتهرت مؤخرا هي رجمه
الصواريخ الامريكيه هاي مارس ام 142 بعد
تسليمها الى اوكرانيا هاي مارس هي رجمه
صواريخ ذاتيه الحركه من انتاج شركه لوكيد
مارتن وبدات الخدمه في الجيش الامريكي في
عام 2010 هذه المنظومه تتكون من سته
صواريخ من فئه المدفعيه الصاروخيه الثقيله
فائقه الدقه يمكن ايضا استبدال هذه
الصواريخ بصاروخ باليستي واحد ويستطيع
اصابه الهدف بمنتهى الدقه من مسافه تصل
الى 500 كلم منظومه هاي مارس تستخدم عده
انواع من الصواريخ من عيار 227 ملم وذلك
طبعا حسب نوع الاهداف يتراوح مدى هذه
القذائف الصاروخيه ما بين 20 و42 كيلومتر
ما يميز عربه 142 التي تحمل هذه المنظ
انها تستطيع السير بسرعه تصل الى 85
كيلومتر في الساعه ما يمنحها طبعا قدره
على التحرك بشكل اكبر في الميدان كما يمكن
نقل هذه المنظومه ايضا عبر الطائرات سي
130 للنقل وبالتالي يمكن ايصالها الى
ميادين القتال بسرعه كبيره منظومه هاي
مارس تم استخدامها في عده حروب منها مثلا
في افغانستان بعد عام 2010 وكذلك في الحرب
ضد تنظيم داعش في سوريا والعراق كما تم
تسليمها مؤخرا الى اوكرانيا ما تسبب حسب
مراقبين في احداث فارق ميداني في سير
المعارك ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا في
المنطقه الشرقيه منظومه هاي مارس توجد لدى
عده دول مثل رومانيا وسنغافوره والامارات
والاردن هذه المنظومه وقوتها ايضا دفعت
العديد من الدول للحديث مع الولايات
المتحده لمحاوله الحصول عليها تم الاتفاق
على تزويد بولندا واستراليا وتايوان بهذه
المنظومه
[موسيقى]
في اعنى في هجوم على الاطلاق انتقد لاول
مره رئيس مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه
صراحه وبالاسم وزير الدفاع الروسيه
متهما اياه بمحاوله تدمير قواته ووصفه
بالخائن
من هو يفقيني بريكوجين الذي يلقب بطباخ
بوتين بريكوجين مؤسس مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه
التي يفترض انها تشكل 10% من جميع القوات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا لكن مهارات بيجوجين
لن تقتصر على ساحات المعركه كونه رجل
اعمال يقوم بدور قائد عسكري صنع ثروته من
خدمات اعداد وتقديم الطعام في التسعينيات
خاصه في المناسبات الرسميه في
اشهر مطاعمه وهو مطعم عائم فاخر بمدينه
سانت بطرسبرج اشتهر المطعم عام 2001 بسبب
تردد بوتين عليه باستمرار وهو الامر الذي
اسفر عن لقب طباخ بوتين الذي اطلق على
بروجين لكن هذا الطرف والرفاهيه وراءهما
السجل المظلم بريكوجين سوجن لمده تسع
سنوات بتهمه السرقه والنصب عندما كان في
العشرينيات من عمره لكنه لم يصنف كمجرم
دولي الا بعد باجنر في عام 2018 خضع طباخ
بوتين عقوبات امريكيه بتهمه تمكين موسكو
بالتلاعب بانتخابات التجديد النصفي
للكونجرس وفي 2020 فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي
عقوبات على رجل الاعمال الروسي على خلفيه
مساهمته في تقويض امن ليبيا وخرق القرار
الاممي بحظر توريد الاسلحه اليها وبعد
الحرب الاوكرانيه اتخذ مسار برغوجين
منعطفا غير متوقع حيث استعرض خلافاته مع
وزير الدفاع الروسيه علنا ولاول مره ووصفه
قائد مجموعه بالخائن اثرى خطوه الوزير
بحرمان مقاتليه من الذخائر حسب بريجين
الذي وجد نفسه بين فك الراحه خارجيا في
اوكرانيا وداخليا في بلاده
بعد مرور عام على الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ما زالت الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في
مصر سلبيه الارتفاع الكبير في اسعار
العديد من السلع وتاثر الاسواق بازمه
استيراد القمح انعكسا على المواطنين
التفاصيل في هذا التقرير
مع حلول الذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه تعد مصر من اكثر الدول تضررا
احد اهم هذه الاسباب هو ان مصر من اكثر
الدول استيرادا للقمح من الدولتين
المتحاربتين
على مدار عام كامل حاولت الحكومه تامين
القمح فوفق الاحصاءات الرسميه فان مصر
تستورد ما يقرب من الخمسه وعشرين مليون طن
سنويا المسار الاول كان التوجه الى
الاسواق البديله وفي السياق الموازن تم
التوسع في انتاج القمح محليا من خلال
زياده الرقع الزراعيه لزراعه القمح في عدد
من المناطق نزرع مناطق جديده في الصحاري
المصريه
لها
خلال مشروع توشكا من خلال شرق العوينات
الوادي الجديد هنا في منطقه قليوب يقوم
عدد من المزارعين بزراعه القمح المشكله من
وجهه نظرهم تكمن في القيمه الماليه
الضئيله التي توفرها الحكومه لشراء القمح
المحلي بتستورد القمح من بره بما قمته
1700 دولار فهي بدل ما تستورده من بره
توفر المزارع وهو منه بنفس القيمه هتوفر
له كتير وهتبقى اوفر له الاضراره السلبيه
لم تقتصر على القمح فقط تعطل سلاسل المؤن
التي سببته الحرب على حركه الملاحه
الدوليه بالاضافه الى الانخفاضات المتكرره
بقيمه الجنيه امام الدولار بسبب قرارات
التعويم تسببت في زياده اسعار الكثير من
المواد الغذائيه ارتفاع اسعار الزيوت
والاعلاف تسببت في زياده كبيره على اسعار
اللحوم والدواجن طبعا في حاله الحرب
هترتفع الاسعار عالميا في توقعات ان هي
هتضاعف الاسعار العالميه في ظل كمان زياده
الطلب على الحبوب من العديد من الدول
العالم وفي ظل محدوديه الموارد المائيه
الاوكرانيه اثرت على الاكصاد في مصر خلال
يزيد خلال سعر السلع كلها تزيد مثلا
البانيه كنا بنجي مثلا 60 جنيه امبارح وصل
250 جنيه مثلا وكل حاجه بقى عماله تزيد في
تزايد مستمر وما فيش حاجه بترخص وفي حين
دفعت تداعيات الحرب الحكومه على ضروره
تطبيق غذائيه جديده تعتمد على الاكتفاء
الذاتي الا ان انتهاء الحرب في اسرع وقت
قد يمثل بارقه امل لملايين المصريين الذين
يعيشون موجات غلاء غير مسبوقه احمد عثمان
العربيه القاهره
التغطيه مستمره مع صهيب شراير
على من الصعب الاماكن التي تركز فيها
القسم
يدعوننا للدخول داخل الملجا
باني يجب ان نتوجه معهم الى مكان ام
ن هو ليس اتفاظ في الشارع وانه هو الطباب
على محطات الوقود
تعاطف كبير مع اللاجئين الاوكرهين
[موسيقى]
يعد هنا هو رائحه الحرير
[تصفيق]
هذا مثلا صفاره الانذار اليوم كل ما خرجنا
من وسط العاصمه تزيد حده الاصوات
[موسيقى]
50 مترا ب8 والكمال تفصيلنا عن مصنع
ازوكستان نحن الان في الطريق الى مدينه
ماريوبل
[موسيقى]
طبعا من يشاهد هذا المنظر يعتقد انه حريق
لهذه البنايات ولكن لكليه الاستهداف
[موسيقى]